hey guys what's up this is andrew for
chainsenses.com so in this video as many
of you were asking me i'm going to show
you a quick presentation about fibonacci
trading so we're going to see
retracements projections i'm going to go
through the entire method you're going
to see that it's actually better to use
when associated with ilia to a theory so
i'm going to show you here the method
many examples and we're going to discuss
about everything that we can find on the
internet and try to see what is true and
what is not so let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so maybe the very first
thing
i'm gonna introduce you to the fibonacci
sequence so basically fibonacci is a
mathematician from the 12th century this
guy was very appreciated by the king at
his time he was a bit a phenomenon
because he was just a genius and when
the king invited him at his court to
solve some enigmas to test him he
actually just kicked everybody's ass he
was the best of the best and this is the
reason why he got so famous and we still
talk about him today so what made him so
famous the first thing is it's sequence
so i'm going to remind you the fibonacci
sequence and i'm going to quickly
explain here how he was actually able to
find it so it all starts with rabbit
guys so basically the fibonacci the
golden number which comes from the
fibonacci sequence can be found
everywhere in nature and fibonacci
identified it
using a small game with rabbits so we're
gonna assume that a pair of rabbits can
have two babies every month and that
they need one month to be fertile to be
able to have babies themselves so you
start at the first month with one pair
of rabbit then the second month they get
fertile
so the third month they're able to have
babies and they remain here and the
month after they're still here the
babies become fertile and they have one
more pair of babies so the fifth month
they're still here their babies are
still here the new babies became fertile
they give birth to new babies and their
first babies who are fertile now are
able to have babies okay so this is
where we are coming from so basically
one
one
two
three
five all right guys so this is the
fibonacci sequence 1 1 2 3 5
8 13 so every
number is the sum of the preceding two
numbers 8 13 21 21 13 34 34 plus 21 55
so on and so forth
so basically what is the fibonacci
sequence it is an additive sequence of
numbers that nature employs in many
processes of growth and decay expansion
and contraction progress and regress so
the global numbers the ratio towards
which converges two consecutive
fibonacci converge two consecutive
fibonacci numbers all right so now
everything i guess is not clear yet but
we have defined what is the fibonacci
sequence how he found it and what is the
golden number so first thing i want to
show you guys is that this golden number
can be found everywhere in nature all
right so in every basically living
growing processes so everything that
contains a spiral you know for example
like a snail like a romanesco broccoli
or all these living plants or animals
that have this kind of shape are
actually built by nature using the
golden ratio so here you can find the
golden ratio for example in the spiral
between every border so between the
center and the border of the spirals
between this and this duration is the
golden number between this
and
this the ratios become the number
between this one and this one sorry the
ratio is the golden number and between
this one and this one the ratio is the
golden number so on and so forth
so is the first thing that we need to be
aware of is that this golden number is
everywhere in nature it is also in the
human hand for example
in every normally constituted person if
you take the ratio between the tip of
the finger and the next part of the
finger it is equal to the golden number
between c and b it's the golden number
two and between b and a it's the golden
number two and you can even go further
between the hand and the forearm is to
call the number and between the forearm
and the entire arm is the golden number
as well and even between the arms and
the full body is the golden number so
the golden number is everywhere in
everything that is growing and markets
are nothing more than a growing process
because it reflects human economy right
so the theory is that it should follow
somehow this golden number and it's more
question of belief
because you know science has not
explained everything yet here we don't
understand why this golden number is
somehow part of a code that is creating
every living plants or animal or you
know human beings but
i believe personally that this golden
number has you know more complex
explanation that we still don't fully
understand so the only thing i would
personally do is to accept the fact that
it's here and try to use it
so let's have a look now at the markets
i'm going to show you the two different
applications that we can have using
fibonacci so either you can use it as
retracements or as projections so we're
going to start with retracement so i'm
sure you guys so many things about that
on the internet
so i'm here gonna probably show you what
you already know but i'm gonna go one
step further and i'm gonna tell you
how to actually to me use this method at
best so the first thing we're going to
do we're going to divide them so i take
the s p 500 i'm on the weekly time frame
i started in 201 to 209 because this is
for me a perfect growing process because
it's developing very well so let's see
how good or bad
this
whole development is following the
golden number so first we need to
identify some moves so we just make
waves okay so this is the first thing to
do we make some waves easy right for now
i didn't do anything complicated now
we're gonna start to check where is the
retracement of each wave going because i
remind you once again that fibonacci is
saying that basically everything that is
growing is making three steps further
two steps back and this is giving you
roughly uh the fibonacci ratio three
divided by two 0.67 fibonacci numbers
0.618 but if you do this forever it's
going to converge towards the
number so here let's measure you know
let's have a look first at what we're
having so i measure from here to here so
for example here it's 23.6
so nothing impressive okay i keep doing
that okay first thing very interesting i
take this wave i checked how deep it has
corrected and i found that it
got a perfect reaction on the 61.8
retracement of this move interesting
okay i keep doing that now i can do it
from here to here but as you can see
guys so here 78.6
so it's still a fib ratio so just one
more thing i need to tell you guys is
that fib ratio are 61.8 percent okay
because this is local number i mean 1
divided by the number then 38.2 because
it's 1 minus 0.618 50
that is just half of the move very
important 100
0 of course
and the smaller one 23.6 and 78.6
okay so those ones are less used but as
you can see sometimes they give us
reactions so for now i'm not talking
about what to do i'm just checking the
facts okay but i can already tell you
that here for example what is
interesting to check is not the
retracement from here to here but the
retracement from here to here
okay
that is 38.2 percent
and i'm not coming to that right away
but one two three four five okay so just
first example to see that if you don't
use elia to a theory
you might not fully grasp the power of
fibonacci
from here to here
okay to the 8.2 percent so for now we
have
this one 23
this one 16 61.8
this one 78.6 but 61.8 of the whole move
up here to the 8.2 so it's quite for now
giving good results then
next one from here to here
38.2 percent okay
interesting
then from here to here
okay 50
okay so still a fib ratio again
and ah here it's not working anymore
okay because we have a new low so then
you need to ask yourself
what is the smooth correcting
so the only way to answer that question
is now to do some earlier 12 theory
right so very quickly earlier to a
theory saying that moves up develop in
five waves one two three four fives and
moves down developing three waves abc
and we're gonna see some projections but
it's too early first just remember we go
we make five waves up and three waves
down so here the first thing i need to
understand
this move what is it correcting which
move up is it correcting so like i said
one two three four five this one quite
easy then here we have an abc okay
then here again one two
three four
and good question but five right
yes
five
so then i need to have five waves here
and we can do something like this okay
so it's working
so then i know that this move down is
correcting
this sequence okay
from here
to here okay because i have five waves
and this is how it's working you need to
identify which move up we are correcting
in order to use your ratios if you don't
apply it to the right portion of the
price action you won't have those
reactions as clean as they would be if
you applied to the right wave counting
so here now if we measure from here to
here
50 okay
so
for now what we're having is
we see
that on the s p 500 since 208
if i check the retracement so basically
the bigger picture is here guys all
right one two
three four and we're doing a five right
okay so let me just change the color of
that
let me change as well the degree this is
an intermediate
counting okay and now we can see that
every retracement inside each wave is
fitting with a golden number ratio and
each correction in the larger degree
wave counting is also fitting with the
golden ratio as you can see here 38.2
wave two from one
and wave four of three fifty percent
so it's still a golden ratio and i'm not
going to do it again but we've seen that
each time here it was correcting have i
checked this one yes and this one 61.8
okay so you can see here wave 4 61.8
with 238.2
wave 2 here
38.2
way four
38.2 so
all of them guys all of them okay so
once again i know the price action after
it happened so it's not easy at all to
make it during the live price action all
right everybody that is going to tell
you it's easy to make money using fibs
is a liar it's not easy at all and you
need once again to associate it very
well with adio2f counting to know where
are the ratios otherwise you just gonna
apply the retracements on the wrong move
so it's not working as good as it could
and here one more thing yes and this one
we checked so here guys i have on the s
p 500 since 208 i have a breakdown in
waves that follows elliot wave theory
and that follows that every wave sub
wave is retracing to a fib ratio of the
previous move up so it's to me already
very interesting to notice it's the
first thing that i wanted to show you so
now that you know that you are able to
try to predict for example here guys
we're in the fifth wave right so in this
fifth wave to me we did maybe one two
okay
so we don't really know
what
if this one is complete or not is it one
two three four five already complete
maybe we don't know it's not obvious
here at all i think we have one two we
have an ongoing third
but if this is a two you see this is
likely not to be a second wave guys
because here or maybe a very shallow one
okay so we don't know but what we know
is that
at some point this whole movie is going
to correct okay so we don't know if we
reach the top or not yet but when it's
going to correct
it's probably going to go to the 38.2
percent so 3650
so it's a very interesting information
to have right to know that at some point
the s p 500 would probably be trading at
3 700. so i'm not saying this year maybe
next year and maybe we're going to move
higher before we correct but ultimately
we're probably going to come back to
this level because this is how things
are happening forever so
okay first information we can get so now
i want to show you something even more
interesting is that this is going to
help you to buy the dip once again so
38.2 percent you can start buying the
deep 50 61.8 percent the truth is that
it's gonna depend on each wave
we are doing elliot wave elliot for
example identified
that second wave is usually
correct to the 61.8 retracement false
wave to the 8.2 percent okay
here and here in reality that's not what
i see what i see is that it's randomly
the 38.2 50 61.8 one of the three all
right and it's to me very random
so i don't fully agree with elliot i
mean just on this of course and what i
am personally doing is that you know i
split my orders at 38.2 50 61.8 i'm
buyers at all these three levels usually
and then i put a stop loss around 78.6
so i'm just going to show for example
here i would be a buyer
so this is how you can start using fibs
all right this is a method that i'm
giving you guys you can start buying at
28.2 add more at 50 add more at 61.8 and
stop everything here and if you do that
i mean if you would have been doing that
on this p500 for the past three years
you would have generated a lot of
profits because the s p 500 is going
higher of course but you would have
beated for sure the the performance of
this index because you would have been
entering each time almost at the low of
the waves so this is how
you can make money using fibonacci but
once again guys i'm telling you that's
not easy my advice would be so depending
on the market you are trading but
sometimes to forget about the 38.2
percent because we can see that
sometimes the corrections are deeper and
to buy for example at this level and
this level and stop for example
everything here okay but if you want to
be more aggressive you need to start
buying here okay on this mp500 you would
have missed most of the moves if you
don't buy the 3840
on other assets you
better off waiting a bit more so it
really depends on what assets you are
trading on the s p 500 personally i
wouldn't wait for the 50 when we're
gonna retrace this whole move up i'm
gonna probably enter the 38.2 percent
which is 3700 and actually even before
right
so it really depends on what kind of
assets you are training so now let's
have a look at fibonacci projections all
right guys so
now i'm going to show you how to use
fibonacci projections so
we're going to stay on the same market
for now then i'm going to show you on
bitcoin
okay
and we're gonna try to see what kind of
projections we had in the past and we're
gonna try to uh deduce from that
how we can predict uh some targets for
for example this fifth wave
and i can already start from here
because elliot already did that work so
you know i can do it again but i can
also start from what he did right and he
said that it really depends on which
wave is extended
so basically
he can break down the market in five
waves almost every time one one two
three four five and depending on which
wave is extended the fifth wave is going
to be a ratio a projection ratio of one
plus three so basically something like
this either the fifth wave is equal to
0.618 times one plus three or if the
fifth is extended it's 1.618 okay you
just divide this by this and you get the
numbers i'm telling you so we're just
going to keep that in mind and we're
going to observe on the market what is
happening for in the past so
we want to have a five waves completion
so that we can analyze the move right so
we're gonna here
uh do some uh elliott wave counting
quickly
so one two
three four five okay this is the first
thing we can do and we are going here
to apply
this
method so we're gonna measure one plus
three and we're gonna apply to the
bottom of the force and
very interestingly
we can see that each time so basically
you have different ratios of fibs okay
the first one is the one to one relation
so here it was at roughly 500
and you can see that every
level and then you have the
number projections so 1.618 just to
explain for those who not fully
understand what i'm doing
you measure one plus three and you're
going to assume that this is your unit
of measure and you're going to apply
this unit of measure to the bottom of
the force wave and then so the one to
one means the move is going to be the
same i'm here using a log scale that's
why you don't see but actually the one
to one means this size is equal to this
size all right i'm going to get back to
log scale
and then we're going to apply ratios for
example that this 1.618 660 is just
equal to the bottom of the force so 200
plus 1.618 times the difference between
the top here and the bottom here which
is roughly 300 310 so 220 10 plus 1.618
times 320 equals roughly 616 okay and
now guys look so elliot is saying that
if the fifth is extended we go here to
the 1.618 and
very interestingly we have
here
this
consolidation around this level and this
is another thing i wanted to tell you
about fibonacci is that sometimes
is giving you very clean reactions but
most of the time it's going to be areas
around which the price action will hover
it will just stay around those levels
because they are like i don't know some
magnets you know to the price action
they're gonna attract the press action
that is gonna stay around it the reason
behind is that many traders are using
those numbers as targets you know for
profit takings and to reload and buy the
dip so here we can see guys that we have
very clean
consolidation just around the golden
number then we go to the next one
and you see okay here we have something
we didn't have any number but otherwise
yes it's very interesting here 2.618
then here perfect reaction
here definitely you cannot deny we have
a consolidation exactly on it this one
is a bit more messy but we have some
reactions then here
guys it's pretty
obvious here as well here okay we have
nothing i agree
and we still have it a bit here so it's
just
very interesting to notice
that
those
projections are giving you areas of
resistance before the price action goes
there so this is the first thing we're
gonna remember now
if i try to but i can see that we are
far from the 1.618 ratios because the
fifth wave here was extremely extremely
extended so i'm gonna try to use the
same method that i'm gonna apply to
another wave so one two
three four five okay
i'm gonna put it in blue
all right
change the degree to the minor and here
we go so we're gonna do the same thing
we're gonna measure because this is what
it is all about one plus three and we're
going to observe
where the fifth wave is going and here
surprise it's going to the 0.618 okay so
i measured one plus three applied to the
bottom of the fourth the tool is here
guys for those who want to try
trend-based fib extension on trading
view and here we go to the open 618
exactly like it was said here guys in
this book written
50 years ago in a third wave extension
we have usually this ratio so the fifth
wave is equal to 0.618 times one plus
three
and this is exactly what happened here
because indeed we can see that the third
wave was extremely long here between the
90s and
uh 98
so once again we have here the field
projection ratio
and we're gonna keep doing that now if i
try to apply it for example we're gonna
check if it was working because we
already have accounting here so we're
gonna just check what kind of ratios did
it give us
oh funny
exactly the same we have a third wave
extended here
and the fifth wave is going to do 0.618
and then correct
okay interesting fact
and what about doing it here
so one plus three
okay this one is not perfect
but we got very close actually it is
guys okay it is not it is not let's be
honest but we are close to the 1.618 so
we are close to the situation when the
fifth wave is extended and so basically
we can see i just applied this tool
three times for now on
all the oneplus 3 i was finding so
basically you can do it pretty much
everywhere and just
you're gonna see by yourself that
usually we go to the 0.618 1 or 1.618
ratios so for example if i apply to the
s p 500 and i measure 1 plus 3 apply to
the bottom of the force this is giving
me so depending if we have a fifth wave
extension or not but for now we are
already above the open 618 that by by
the way gave us a reaction here at
roughly four thousand so my guess is
that we're gonna have a fixed wave
extension and that we're gonna get close
to the one point six one eight six
thousand six hundred so this is a very
interesting information i can have using
fibs on the global markets i already
know that we would probably go some at
some point to the 3700 level and i also
know i mean i believe that we're gonna
go at some point at six thousand six
hundred
so this is of course a long term process
maybe i'm not sure in which way we're
gonna start probably with the dip first
so it's not easy to build up a view here
but i'm still gonna try and what i would
say
is that sorry i'll keep getting rid of
that so maybe we're gonna push a bit
higher first then correct the 3700 level
okay
and then complete this this move and
then maybe we're gonna have a deeper
correction all right
i believe that at some point the market
is gonna correct this entire move
because we have a lot of this is a third
fourth and this is a fifth all right so
at some point we're going to correct
this entire move but this is not the
point of this video uh the point of this
video is just to show you how to use
those ratios and to remind you that of
course it's not easy so here my view can
only be that we push higher right now or
maybe lower right now i don't know but
we gonna go to the 3700 level at some
point and i'm gonna be a massive buyer
at this level because i believe we're
going to go to the 6500 level after that
all right so you can see already two
strong implications that's coming are
coming in my view from fibonacci and
angular 2 3 apply together now i want to
show you another thing on the bitcoin so
i have prepared that already so it's
going to be quick it's giving you
fantastic results all right basically
you need to go to markets that are
really growing if you take a range
market fibonacci will not give you
amazing results but if you take bull
market
then it's usually quite impressive so
here what i did guys i just measured
this entire move started in 2015 to the
first
top at uh in 2018-17
around 20 000. i applied to the bottom
here and i have my production levels
and
once again guys
it's very disturbing to see
that
those levels
are magnets okay you can see you have
all the feed ratios and almost every
high or low that you have and
consolidation is building around these
levels so it's like
uh you know in the universe you have the
dark matter and it's actually
ruling the space between
the matter between every planet
like magnets so we don't fully
understand the dark matter and we don't
fully understand fibs as well right we
don't know why it's basically hovering
around those levels but it's just the
market structure it's like this it's
probably coming from the fact
that the price action is just the
collective subjectivity of every
investor that you know
act as a as a mass as a group and
whenever you have some complex system
like this that when you have this group
we have behavioral mechanisms that are
at place i think there is maybe
something you know that is
controlling all of this thought
processes and without even knowing
when we act as a group we actually
converge to what nature is doing which
is basically using the golden number
everywhere that's the best i can tell
you that's really what i think once
again it's maybe a question of belief
but you can't ignore the facts that are
here and you can check every growing
stock crypto whatever
you're gonna see if you do the small
exercise that i've just done that this
golden number is everywhere and if you
want really to understand how to use it
for trading so i invite you to read
elliot wave book where he gives a lot of
information about the ratios
and once again
my method i remind you again is just to
identify the wave counting then you
start to
measure the potential corrections and
depending on how it was happening in the
past you're gonna place your orders
between 38.2 and 61.8 percent and you're
gonna stop everything around 78.6
because once we go there usually we make
a new low so if you did enjoy this video
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're going to
be the first to know when i upload
anything new and stay close to shore see
you guys